[Musique]
bienvenue au Parlement européen pour un
dialogue un débat sinon européen la
crise covid a mis un peu plus en exergue
notre dépendance économique et
industrielle un vis-à-vis de la Chine
avec une pénurie de matériel médicaux et
de médicaments et notre dépendance face
à la Chine aux géants chinois 9 faiblit
pas avec la crise d'approvisionnement
des semis conducteurs notre déficit
commercial c'est encore creuser cette
dernière année pour atteindre 92
milliards d'euros à la faveur donc de
Pékin oui alors si j'ai une ping vient
de célébrer les 10 ans de son accession
à la tête du Parti communiste chinois
mais il fait de moins en moins figure de
partenaires fiables et stables pour les
Européens l'attitude de la Chine est
plus ambigu dans la guerre en Ukraine
dont elle espère peut-être tirer des
bénéfices par un lien privilégié avec la
Russie et puis les relations ce tendent
aussi avec les 27 désormais qui veulent
retrouver une souveraineté économique et
stratégique alors que Pékin a cherché en
quelque sorte elle est divisée en leur
proposant des liens économiques
particuliers à travers le projet Route
de la Soie alors nous en dépatons sur ce
plateau avec deux invités de femmes et
une journaliste chinoise bonjour Camille
Chen rédactrice en chef du service
français de mandarra TV et Marie-Pierre
vedren bonjour euro député françaises
Renault et vice-présidentin de la
Commission du commerce international
Marie-Pierre vedren en 2022 est-ce qu'on
peut dire que lieu s'éveille enfin de
partenaires à à concurrent la Chine est
devenue un adversaire je dirais que
l'Union européenne elle s'est déjà pas
réveillée en fait dès 2019 en vis-à-vis
de la Chine là
parce qu'en fait en 2019 la Commission
européenne avec les institutions
européennes ont adopté un petit peu leur
vision vis-à-vis de la Chine un
partenaire parce qu'on a besoin de la
Chine pour relever le défi du changement
climatique un concurrent économique et
on y reviendra et vous l'avez exposé
rien qu'avec le balance commerciale et
puis un rival systémique donc le constat
il était déjà mais le choc du covid la
guerre en Ukraine renforce ce constat
que nous avions fait puis on voit aussi
un renforcement de certains
comportements de la Chine qui passe de
seulement concurrence déloyale à
l'utilisation aussi de la coercition
économique donc le constat est là
maintenant c'est comment les leviers les
instruments les décisions qu'on prend
répondent à ces objectifs en même temps
j'ai envie de dire du côté chinois vous
n'avez pas trop de soucis à vous faire
vous continuez à avoir un très très bon
très bon chiffre d'exportation en
direction du marché on le disait le
déficit commercial c'est c'est creuser
évidemment un autre défaveur et ce
malgré la fermeture de vos frontières
depuis deux ans pour cause de covid
fermeture que les Européens jugent
d'ailleurs un petit peu excessive non
oui et certainement du point de vue
européen la fermeture des frontières
chinoises et excessives cela étant je
pense que cela la fermeture des
frontières est d'ailleurs les frontières
commencent à s'ouvrir ça correspond à la
nécessité du gouvernement chinois de
protéger sa population contre le covid
19 qui ne cesse de surgir en fait c'est
pour des raisons tout à fait sanitaires
cela étant je pense que quand on parle
du déficit commercial il faut pas avoir
je vais dire une prise
européenne il faudrait aussi la replacer
dans un contexte d'échange commercial
beaucoup plus global si la Chine a un
excellent commercial avec l'Union
européenne elle a contracté on va dire
des déficites commerciaux avec ces
autres partenaires et pourquoi est-ce
que il y a ce déficit commercial je
pense que c'est parce que si les
Européens achètent beaucoup plus de
marchandises de la Chine c'est parce un
besoin elle a besoin vital et j'ai la
Chine il y a un besoin vital en
particulier sur les métaux rares et
stratégiques comme le lithium ou les
terres des matériaux nécessaires et
indispensables notamment pour écrire un
monde bacarbone sur l'avant-dernière
devant faire une priorité pour les 27
enfin Marie-Pierre Védrenne il y a il y
a urgence depuis longtemps on dit que
l'Union européenne doit être capable de
décider par elle-même quand avec qui
comment elle veut établir des relations
commerciales nous l'enjeu c'est pas de
dire que on veut pas de relation avec la
Chine parce que comme je l'ai dit la
Chine doit être engragée notamment sur
la question du changement climatique
donc on doit avoir un agenda positif
avec la Chine mais qu'est-ce qu'on voit
qu'on a des problématiques dans un ordre
politique sur la question des wigours
sur la question de Hong Kong et puis on
a cette dépendance véritablement
économique sur certaines matières
premières donc c'est vrai les métaux
rares c'est stratégique c'est
stratégique là on voit notre dépendance
vis-à-vis de la situation avec l'Ukraine
et la Russie on a une dépendance sur le
gaz sur l'énergie et sur d'autres
matières premières sur la Chine c'est
effectivement les métaux rares et le
lithium et le lithium en particulier et
toute la logique comprend pour le Green
Deal si on prend les voitures
électriques Electric aussi on a besoin
même pour nos téléphones de ces enjeux
donc l'objectif c'est de dire on doit
agir sur plusieurs leviers on doit nous
refaire une production européenne donc
là c'est notre production industrielle
c'est le rôle de Thierry Breton et puis
on ne doit sortir de cette dépendance
donc c'est pas la volonté de dire stop à
toute relation avec qui que ce soit mais
c'est des relations qui soient
équitables qui soit basé sur une
concurrence royale mais qui surtout
aussi respecte des fondamentaux qui sont
aussi les questions des valeurs des
droits de l'homme on parlait de ces
fameux métaux lourds du lithium 70% de
la production mondiale c'est ce que vous
représentez 70% aujourd'hui c'est
évidemment énorme on le disait ce sont
des ce sont effectivement des matériaux
absolument indispensables fabrication
d'un certain nombre de choses et
notamment la transition écologique même
pour est-ce que cette vous faites
marcher en quelque sorte ce qu'on
appelle la diplomatie minérale
c'est-à-dire la diplomatie des métaux
est-ce que c'est une accusation ou c'est
un constat quand vous dites que la Chine
on va dire fait de la diplomatie en la
matière moi je dirais que c'est pousser
le bouchon un peu trop loin c'est voir
les choses sont un angle beaucoup trop
négatif alors en ce qui concerne les
métaux rares moi je les ai étudiés de
façon approfondie c'était il y a à peu
près 10 ans à l'époque la Chine c'était
le premier producteur mondial ça reste
toujours le premier producteur mondial
de métaux rares à l'époque la production
chinoise représentait aux alentours de
90% donc de la protection mondiale déjà
à l'époque l'Union européenne voulait
que les Chinois exportent davantage du
point de vue européen votre position
rentable parce que vous avez besoin de
métaux rares pour fabriquer des produits
à haute valeur ajoutée pour les besoins
de la défense de la Défense nationale
n'est-ce pas parce que les métaux rares
sont indispensables mais il faudrait
aussi je pense se placer si vous le
pouvez tu point de vue des Chinois et
pourquoi la Chine a décidé il y a 10 ans
déjà de restreindre l'exportation de ces
métaux rares pour deux raisons
fondamentales vous parliez tout à
l'heure du respect de la de la
production de l'environnement il faut
savoir que la production des métaux
rares est extrêmement
dangereuse pour l'environnement
extrêmement polluante et très nocive
pour la santé et c'est la raison pour
laquelle quand la Chine on va dire quand
elle a franchi les premiers pas de la
phase dans la phase d'industrialisation
parce qu'avant c'était quand même
l'usine du monde aujourd'hui à la Chine
a fait un grand pas en avant pour pour
être capable de produire des on va dire
des produits à haute valeur ajoutée ce
n'était pas le cas il y a 10 ans à
l'époque où l'Europe avait un
urgent besoin de matière première mais
déjà elle a pris conscience de la
nécessité de ce protéger la Chine c'est
quand même pas la poubelle du monde
n'est-ce pas et surtout et en fait la
production de terrain ça nécessite
plusieurs années de travail de
l'extraction à la production donc la
Chine aussi c'était en pleine phase
d'indurcial je termine là-dessus elle
avait besoin aussi de garder ces métaux
rares pour ses propres besoins donc
je pense que si vous essayez de
comprendre cette position vous
comprendrez aussi l'attitude de la Chine
donc pour moi
en faire faire de la question des
méthodes une diplomatie pour moi c'est
un peu trop fort c'est un peu trop fort
en fait quoi pour moi la question
effectivement c'est valable sur sur les
métaux rares et c'est valable sur sur
d'autres matières premières et d'autres
enjeux c'est pas quoi la Chine à sa
propre politique sa propre stratégie il
y a beaucoup de choses très très
contestables et puis l'Union européenne
doit défendre ses fondamentaux et
retrouver sa souveraineté chacun défense
c'est ses intérêts mais la difficulté
moi ce qui me gêne c'est que si je
prends des exemples aussi par exemple de
volonté de la Lituanie qui veut se
rapprocher de Taïwan c'est comment la
Chine derrière va utiliser la coercition
économique et là c'est même pas des
conditions de concurrence loyale c'est
utiliser une décision politique
souveraine d'un État membre de l'Union
européenne ou de l'Union européenne pour
contraindre des choix souverains d'un
État membre de l'Union européenne il est
là le problème et là c'est vrai que
l'Union européenne était quand même
démunie en la matière donc on vient
d'adopter un nouvel instrument dans
notre commission va rentrer en débat
avec les institutions européennes parce
que on voit aussi et ça rejoint votre
première question sur l'Europe la fin de
la naïveté la concrétisation on a le
constat est bon mais on n'a pas les
leviers qui nous permettent de rétablir
une relation et répondre avec la Chine
et de répondre aux enjeux moi je suis
pas et c'est là où je pense que je suis
pas contre la Chine c'est pas ça mon
enjeu je suis député européenne vous
l'avez dit je suis française je défends
les intérêts français et européens et on
sait qu'on doit avoir comme je le disais
un agenda positif avec la Chine sur des
questions fondamentales sur les
questions environnementales sur les
questions des respects des droits de
l'homme donc on doit travailler en
commun mais on le voit bien que la
question juste de dire à la Chine il
faut bouger sur tel sujet il faut
avancer sur la question des ouigos il y
a pas il y a pas de changement d'où la
nécessité interne à l'Union européenne
de faire son travail et se donner de ses
instruments c'est une question de
géopolitique madame chienne a manié la
Chine
un dictateur expansionniste qui remet en
cause le droit international comme
Vladimir Poutine ça va pas rassurer ni
les investisseurs ni les pays européens
là l'ambiguïté est-ce qu'il faut la
lever la Chine par rapport à la lentille
est-ce que vous pouvez être beaucoup
plus clair parce que pour moi
l'Antiquité quand vous utilisez le terme
en piqueté à mon avis cela relève du
fait que peut-être que
ici en Europe on ne parle pas assez de
la politique étrangère de la Chine et si
je peux me permettre d'en dire plus
puisque je suis enfin je ne suis pas
chapitre craignant est-ce que la Chine
justement alors là c'est la deuxième
question à laquelle je vais vous
répondre et je réponds d'abord à la
question de Madame alors l'Antiquité
alors je ne pense pas que ce soit
en PQ pour la Chine pourquoi parce que
dès le départ la Chine a toujours
clarifié sa position sur la question du
conflit militaire où ils sont ukrainien
la police parce que il faudrait
comprendre d'abord la politique
étrangère de la Chine pour comprendre on
va dire son attitude la Chine a toujours
dit dès le début je me souviens très
très bien parce que en tant que
journaliste franco-chinoise je suis de
près à la fois l'actualité française et
aussi l'actualité chinoise alors je vois
que la politique étrangère dans la Chine
n'a jamais varié depuis présentation en
1949 en fait il y a plusieurs points
importants à retenir premier point sa
position ça a toujours considéré à dire
il faut respecter il faut pas s'ingérer
dans les affaires intérieures de la
Chine deuxièmement la Chine a toujours
prôné là coexistence pacifique et
troisièmement ça c'est le point le plus
important la Chine a toujours dit si
vous avez fait attention à cette
actualité
c'est que il faut résoudre le problème
du conflit russo-ukrainien par voie
pacifique par voie de dialogue et de
négociation il n'y a pas eu d'ambiguïté
en la matière votre attitude ressemble
un peu à celle de journaliste américain
et du gouvernement américain on va dire
globalement de la position de l'OTAN qui
consiste à dire voilà donc sur la
question sur la question du conflit
Rousseau Ukrainiens il faut choisir
votre camp je regrette la Chine dans un
pays souverain et en tant que souverain
et n'a pas à se laisser dicter sa
politique sa position voilà et d'autant
plus que elle a déjà clarifié sa
position on ne s'ingère pas dans les
affaires intérieures ça pose peut-être
un problème c'est est-ce que finalement
la Chine elle est en train de faire
affaire avec Vladimir Poutine pour ce
qui est de la vente de son gaz et de
l'exportation de son pétrole qu'elle
nous revendrait d'ailleurs qu'elle
achèterait moins cher et qu'elle nous
revendrait plus cher et donc contourner
en quelque sorte les sanctions
européennes ça c'est une vraie question
pour elle je joue la Chine sur la
question ukrainienne bah moi je
j'entends ce que vous dites madame mais
je évidemment je partage pas votre
analyse
j'entends ce que vous dites sur la
souveraineté de la Chine pas d'ingérence
et quand vous nous dites les questions
qui sont posées par les journalistes
sont des questions des journalistes
américains non c'est des questions
légitimes ressemblent oui mais c'est des
questions que légitimement en tant
qu'Européen nous nous avons le droit de
vous adresser c'est pas que ce soit
légitime pas du tout j'ai dit j'entends
ça le retour d'une guerre sur le
territoire on voit bien que Vladimir
Poutine rappelons-le à violer le droit
international nous l'Union européenne ce
qu'on demande et ce qu'on promet c'est
le respect des règles du droit
international et on le voit que
malheureusement sur cette application
que ça soit sur de la diplomatie de la
politique étrangère ou que ça soit sur
des questions économiques la Chine
malheureusement ne respecte pas les
règles du jeu on a un cadre multilatéral
qui en plus subi quand même des
difficultés on veut une Chine engagée
qui respecte les règles sur l'ensemble
des questions c'est pas je voulais redis
notre logique c'est effectivement c'est
un partenaire stratégique avec lequel
nous devons avoir un agenda positif
c'est un concurrent ça c'est l'Union
européenne qui doit faire son propre
travail sur sa politique commerciale
sortir de sa dépendance travailler sur
la diversification c'est nous Européens
qui devons agir et d'ailleurs Bruxelles
a pour ambition de bannir les produits
importés du travail forcé dans le train
dans le viseur de la Commission
européenne des droits de l'homme bafouer
des ouigo et là c'est l’ingérence
vis-à-vis de la Chine non c'est la
protection de notre marché intérieur la
politique commerciale aussi sur tous ces
enjeux c'est nos politiques intérieures
qu'on projette on a un marché intérieur
sur lequel nous avons quand même la
légitimité le droit parce que nous
devons assurer aussi la protection de
des citoyens européens de dire que des
produits
issus du travail français c'est valable
pour la Chine mais c'est valable pour
tout autre État non pas à rentrer sur
notre marché mais enfin la Chine elle se
sent visée par cette question wego quand
même c'est vrai oui effectivement je
pense que bon en Europe en Occident on
parle beaucoup de la question des 8
cours mais je pense que la question des
huit cours
si je peux me donner si je peux vous
donner mon point de vue c'est une
question qui a été montée de toutes
pièces c'est une question qui a été
fabriquée alors je préfère vous le dire
oui je regrette madame je préfère vous
le dire avec votre opinion
qui démontrent quand même la réalité des
faits vous avez vous études mais j'ai
aussi mes études on a quand même une
question récurrente aussi avec les
démocrates Hong Kong et on a quand même
la question de Taïwan
doit continuer à avancer sur ces enjeux
l'Union européenne a cette volonté de
devenir souveraine de décider avec qui
quand comment elle veut commercialiser
nous devons travailler avec tout le
monde c'est capital mais il faut aussi
être là
merci mais là